Good evening, everybody.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliff,
and I'm glad to welcome
you here to another $15K
Creative Arts
Competition workshop.
This evening we're going to be
focusing on for-profit ventures
and business plans
with Carly Chase.
I'm joined by Theo Fields.
Say hello, Theo.
Hi, everyone.
And we've got some conversation
that we're going to have.
Carly is going to share a lot
of her wealth of intelligence
with us.
We'll have some Q&A. So
without further ado, Carly,
do you want to do a
quick introduction
and then launch right in?
Absolutely, yeah.
That is part of my--
Perfect
So let me just share my slides.
And I know that this
is being recorded,
and I assume will be heard
by others potentially,
but just so we give those
of us who are on the call
the most benefit,
Diana and Sida,
tell me if I just
pronounced your name wrong,
or if I completely butchered it.
Is it Sida or Sida?
Sida.
No worries.
I took a 50-50 chance, and I
was on the wrong side of that.
I want to make sure this
is as useful for you
guys as possible.
So if you want to give me
any context about what you're
working on so I can
tailor this to that,
and then we can talk through
specific things in regards
to your own businesses.
I would love to do
that if you guys just
want to sit back and
listen, no pressure.
So maybe-- I can't see your
faces, and that's totally fine.
But do you guys want to
talk about your business?
Do you want to not talk
about your business?
Maybe just give me an
idea before we jump in.
Sure, I'm happy to give
you my 30-second pitch,
but I also recognize other folks
might view this video later.
So definitely don't tailor
everything to our ideas.
So I'm working on an
idea that so far I'm
calling Fuse, exact
name TBD, and also
going to be part of the--
sorry, Muse.
It's going to be part of
the Fuse program after IHP.
Awesome, congrats.
Thank you.
So I'm excited to
work on it over IAB.
And the idea-- the need
that I'm trying to solve
is that art supplies today
is really, really expensive
and primarily purchased through
brick-and-mortar stores.
And there's no good places
online to buy anything.
And for artists who are
aspiring to do stuff--
for aspiring artists,
it's actually really hard
to get started.
So my idea right now is to
create a digitally native art
supply purchasing
experience that can help
aspiring artist get started.
That's awesome, cool.
And do you have a team that
you're working on this with?
I don't have a
team, unfortunately,
but I am looking
for a [INAUDIBLE]
This is going to be tailored
actually well to you, then.
OK, perfect.
And Diana, do you want
to give us a shout?
Or are you just going
to hang with us?
Well, I just knew a few
things about this program,
but my intention is to
learn more-- something that
can help me in the
future because I want
to be an ACT of the MIT
Art, Culture and Technology
candidate for a master.
Cool.
So that's why I wanted to
know more and be more involved
in the programs that MIT has.
Awesome.
Good, All right, cool.
OK, so we'll get started,then.
So my name is Carly.
I think that whenever you're
listening to a presentation,
you should get context for where
all of this is coming from.
There's no hard and fast
rules in entrepreneurship,
and there is no
single framework.
So therefore,
everything in my opinion
is an opinion that you're
going to hear from anybody
in entrepreneurship.
It's just based on
their own experiences,
and the range of experiences of
entrepreneurs is really vast.
And so the context--
and to basically
contextualize what
I'm going to tell you today
is based on my own experience.
So I want to give you
the full context on me.
So I started my career at
Goldman Sachs in finance.
I lived through the 2008
financial crisis there.
Stayed a number of
years after that,
and then decided that the
corporate world which I thought
was going to be my entire
career, that I was going
to try something else on,
that maybe this wasn't
going to be the most fun place
for the rest of my career.
And decided to go join
the local government
in New York City,
where I actually live
and still live today.
I'm in Brooklyn right now.
So I worked for Mayor Michael
Bloomberg's administration
in economic development.
And back then, this was
about eight years ago,
New York was trying
to figure out
how to compete after
the financial crisis,
how to diversify our
economy, and one way
was to bring more
startups to New York.
So we were trying
to figure out, how
do we compete with San
Francisco and London and Boston,
and make New York more
attractive for founders.
The arts was a huge existing
industry in New York,
for instance.
So we said, what are the
assets that we already have?
And how can we get
more entrepreneurs
to feel confident that
New York is a great place
to not only start, but be
able to grow their business?
So I worked with
a lot of founders.
Sort of figured out what the
perceived and real challenges
were with coming to New
York, and that's really
how I got my startup bug.
So then I decided to really
try out startups and was hired
as the general manager of a
real estate tech startup--
another industry that's
enormous in New York--
real estate, and was the
founder of the New York
office for a real estate
market place called PivotDesk.
I did that for a number
of years until we
were sold to a national
co-working provider called
Industrious.
And then since have been
within either a full-time or
consulting capacity, and now I
advise a couple of early stage
startups, a number of
venture-backed startups,
and also have my own
non-venture-backed startup,
which is another option
for people who are starting
their own business.
They don't always have to do
the full venture-backed crazy
accelerated growth business
model called Crabwalk,
which is all about helping
people get ownership over
their careers and this
new way of work where--
I thought, like I
already mentioned,
I was at Goldman Sachs.
I thought I was going to be
there and go up a ladder.
There is no ladder anymore,
so people need a lot more help
in navigating their careers.
And in between that all,
I found myself here at MIT
where I have been for about 3
and 1/2 years an entrepreneur
in residence at the
Trust Center running
a number of our
extracurricular programs,
including our accelerator
program, delta v and our Intro
to Entrepreneurship
bootcamp [INAUDIBLE] MIT.
I also am a senior lecturer
for two classes, and as an EIR
get to coach a
bunch of students,
which is a ton of fun.
So since we're going to be
talking about business plans,
I will tell you that I've seen--
I've had the privilege of
seeing so many business
plans at this point, both
from early in my career
and now at MIT talking to
lots of different students
who work on lots of different
industries and problems.
And if you guys could
tell me for anybody
who wants to respond,
I'm just curious
what you hear by
a business plan,
because I feel like this
is a really big topic.
There's business
plan competitions,
there's business
plan submissions,
there's financial projections.
I'm just curious any
perceptions that people
have about what is this
business plan thing anyways.
I can show you what I
tend to think of it as.
It's your go-forward plan for
how you intend to make revenue
through what strings.
How you intend to be
a viable business.
And not only viable
at point of launch,
but also sustainable
going forward.
Yeah, I really like that.
So I agree that a lot
of business plans are--
when I think of business plan,
I also put it adjacent to money
and I put it adjacent to
profits and profitability.
And the thing about a businesses
is that is the ultimate goal.
You do not have a
business unless you
have paying customers.
That is a core role of
ours at the trust center.
But I really think about
the business plan as helpful
in a lot of ways.
And so that's really--
that's the end goal and what
Sida really hit on the head
is we need a direction, right?
A lot of times in
entrepreneurship things
are going so fast,
and you just want
to get to the next goal
and the next milestone
and the next milestone.
But if you don't actually
have a direction,
if you don't know where
you're going in the long run,
you're going to
miss a lot of stuff.
Your vision will probably
actually narrow down smaller
to what it really could
be if you took a moment
to look around and
understand the full picture
and set a direction yourself.
So I really love this quote that
Brad Feld, who actually happens
to be an MIT grad, and as a
really prominent and famous
venture capitalist, I
have a lot of respect for.
And he says, it's
a critical document
for an entrepreneur to
organize their thoughts
around their new business.
And this is what I think
is really critical.
So I think see that you really
hit the nail on the head
in terms of what the
ultimate goal is.
It is to get revenue and to
create a sustainable business.
Because without
customers and revenue,
there is no
sustainable business.
But I really think, and I
really love this phrasing,
that a business plan is an
opportunity for you to really
organize your thoughts.
And to me, one of the
biggest goals or reasons
why you'd want to
organize your thoughts
is so you can communicate them.
Because really, your
job as an entrepreneur
at the end of the day
is to set a vision
and communicate your vision.
Right?
That's so you can raise
money from investors
and so you can find teammates
and have co-founders
and eventually employees.
It's so you can talk to
partners and customers.
Really having a way to
organize your thoughts
so you can communicate them
out is really, really key.
And frankly, it's something
that I really see as undervalued
in most entrepreneurs.
They just think the product is
the important thing to refine,
and I'll just wing my
messaging or the way I pitch.
And that is really, I would
almost say, the opposite.
Good product is a must have.
You don't really have a
business if you don't have
something exciting to sell.
But if you can't
communicate that out,
it really doesn't matter
in the first place.
And just piggybacking
off of that,
it's one of the
elemental aspects
of the $15K specifically.
I think that it's necessary
to have bedrock business
fundamentals, but
especially in the arts.
We don't have as many
quantitative measures
to be able to convey
in a slide, and I
think that while pitches
are really important,
I think that we really
emphasize and value
a really clear communicative,
persuasive, and engaging pitch
maybe above other--
almost anything else.
Yeah, totally.
And so these are a few
reasons that I came up
to give you a whole set
of reasons as to why you
do a business plan,
but I would actually
move your eyes to the third
one in the middle of the slide.
Because this is really how I
think about a business plan.
It's like this master document
you have that helps you.
It's your business plan--
this version of
your business plan,
at least, you're
going to have lots
of versions of
your business plan
depending on who
the audience is.
And we can talk about what the
different audiences you'll need
it for, I just mentioned a few.
But think of this plan that
I'm talking about today
as your master document that's
an internal document that's
just for you.
It's a living
document that you're
going to update all
the time and iterate on
so that you can pull
from it when you're
talking to a specific audience.
So, OK, here's my master plan.
It has 15 different sections.
When I'm talking to an
investor versus a customer,
I'm going to need to
pull different sections
and insights from it.
Not everybody should see
everything about your business.
And you should be
really thoughtful
and you'll learn how to do that
over time about what to share
and frankly, what not to share.
And that's a whole other
different communication
skill set that we could talk
about at a different time.
And so I would argue I think
a lot of business plans
are talked about in
PowerPoint or even Excel
when you think about
financial projections.
I would argue unless you love
PowerPoint, and some people do,
I personally don't--
this is even keynote,
a better version of PowerPoint
in my opinion that I use today.
But I really like
text, especially when
we're talking communication.
I think it's so important to
be able to write succinctly
and compellingly in text.
Because that's how
we communicate.
We talk on the phone, we write
emails, we write proposals.
And PowerPoint is one way to
communicate, but in my head
it's not the world's best way
to get out all of your thoughts.
It could be a high level
version of your thoughts.
And you can take
that master text
and translate it into PowerPoint
for different audiences.
But again, my two cents,
my personal opinion,
my personal experience,
I don't necessarily
think PowerPoint is the way to
communicate your business plan.
So again, we talked about
this a little before,
but who is a business plan for?
I just put a scenario out here,
and for Sida, you to could even
say just one co-founder now.
Say you're two co-founders,
you started working together
in September at the
beginning of the school year,
and you want to recruit
other team members
and enter competitions soon.
Maybe you've done some
primary market research,
you've begun to prototype.
So we need a master document.
So we're two co-founders,
or I'm one person
that works by myself.
Or maybe I'm-- a typical
scenario is somebody,
maybe a professor or
PI and two students,
working to
commercialize research.
And what this document
can do for you
as co-founders, or team members,
or for a single person who's
working on their business.
This is just an opportunity
to coalesce your thoughts,
and to write down everything
that's happening today.
It's a what's happened
up to now document.
And where do I want
to go from here?
And again, you're
going to iterate
this, and iterate, and
iterate, and refine it
depending on the audience
you're talking to.
But this is almost one
of the first things
you should do in your
business in my opinion.
Because-- especially when you
have multiple people involved.
This is also a great document
if you do have a co-founder
or you do have team
members, to also
make sure you guys
are on the same page.
It's really easy to
assume that you're
going in the same direction, but
if you don't actually check in
and confirm that you
could easily be diverging.
And so the earlier in your
venture you can do this,
the more aligned you're
going to be in the long run.
So when we think about what
should be in my business plan--
and this is going to be
a really long slide--
but we can talk too, and
we can talk to whatever
people want to talk about.
But these are suggestions.
These are what I've
seen in business plans.
And you might be able to fill
in all of these sections today,
and you might not be able to.
And I think as much as
you need to understand
and comprehend what
you currently have,
it's also an opportunity to
figure out what don't I have?
What haven't I thought about?
Or what haven't I
figured out yet?
Or what am I less confident in?
And again, the benefit
of putting this in text
is you can also use this
document to get feedback.
One thing that entrepreneurs
need to be good at
is asking for help.
And so not only
asking for help, like
I'm really bad at
creating a vision.
That's something that scares me.
I'm really good at saying in
the near term what I want,
but what is that really-- what
could that be in the long term?
Or I'm less great at
understanding unit economics,
can I get some feedback on this?
This business plan
hopefully empowers
you to go and get the advice
and the support you need.
And also to be able to check in
and say this makes sense to me,
does this make sense
to somebody else?
And that overarching
goal of communication.
And again, this is just
a list of suggestions
that you should absolutely
customize to your business
and your stage of business.
If you're that scenario
that I just put before this,
it's probably pretty hard to
have financial projections
at this point.
And that's totally OK.
Just leave it open, and
know that every time
you get a clue for that section
just add it add it back in.
OK, so just to go through
these really quick.
Just going to switch
where my Zoom is so
I can see every single bullet.
So starting with your mission
statement and your vision
statement.
And I think there's a
big question sometimes
about the difference
between these two.
To me, a vision is
really the direction
you want to go in long term.
Maybe it's not--
has nothing to do
with the way you're
going to go to market
or your first customer.
It's really how do I
see this business having
impact in the long run?
What is the ultimate
goal of this business?
And the mission statement
is really close to that.
But that's almost
why am I doing this?
Or why are we doing
this as a team?
Why is this important
in the world?
Or in my industry?
Or to my customer?
So vision, or the direction
you want to go, and mission,
I would say why
this is important.
The next most important thing.
What is the problem
you're solving?
So, so important to be
able to succinctly state.
This is actually sometimes
one of the hardest things
to do because you
start with a problem,
and then you decide to go
talk to a bunch of customers.
And then you sort
of pivot from where
you started to more of what
you're hearing in the customers
and back again.
A lot of times all of the
different customer research
we do, and market research we
do, creates a maze in our heads
as entrepreneurs.
I don't know if that's
making sense and resonating
with folks.
That typically does when
I'm teaching to my students.
And again, taking an opportunity
to really try to write out
the problem you're solving.
It might sound trivial, but
it's actually, in my opinion,
one of the hardest parts
of the business plan.
Then you want to talk about
all of the market research
you've done.
So I've talked to
these many customers,
or prospective customers.
I've researched the
market landscape.
I understand the history of the
problem I'm trying to solve.
I understand the context
I'm trying to operate in.
I understand those
who are currently
trying to solve this problem.
Here is who's tried it in
the past and why they failed.
And then you go on
to your solution.
Here is the solution to
the problem I'm solving.
Here is-- if it's a product that
you've prototyped so far, have
product specs, or a product
brochure, you can put that in.
Here is the way I'm going to
develop this product over time.
That'll get to,
eventually, the resources
that you need to
create this company.
And then here's how I'm actually
going to put this into market.
This is how I'm
going to get started.
Here's the first
customer I started with.
If you guys are familiar
with the concepts
of beachhead market and persona.
Who is my primary customer?
And how am I going
to reach them?
Am I going to do traditional--
is it a consumer product?
Do I have to do traditional
digital marketing?
Is that a B2B product?
Or am I going to have
a direct sales process?
Is it a medical device?
Am I going to have licensing
agreements with existing
distribution partners?
What's your idea for how
you get started here?
And then of course
I know that Shannon
said you guys are going to
have a workshop on value
propositions.
I think another-- such
an important piece
of communication
for your business.
Really to understand
the value that you're
delivering, especially
for this primary customer.
And then eventually, I do think
business model unit economics,
financial projections,
those probably
come a little bit
later, just because you
do need some information
to really understand
the world you're operating in.
You might have some
initial assumptions,
that is great to include.
And then the team.
The team is a really important
part of your business plan.
Who is working on this?
What are your skill sets?
What is your
existing experience?
Why are you interested in this?
And perhaps you might even
have a couple of blank people.
Things you need--
people you need to find
or skill sets you
need to acquire.
So again, it can be your
existing business plan,
especially when you're
really early stage,
because this can really serve
as an internal document for you.
It can be, here's all
the things we've done
and here's all the sections
and questions that we still
need to fill out and answer.
And then finally, what
this really helps you do
is figure out what
resources do I have
and what resources do I need.
And so if you've actually
mapped all of this out, and this
is a lot of work
on a single slide.
I'm not trying to
diminish the level of work
that this is to create and
write something like this,
then you can say, OK, here
are the resources I need.
Here's the type of
financing that I need
to get this off the ground.
Here's the team
I need to create.
Maybe you have a section
of even here's advisors
I'd love to have.
Here are random-- whatever the
resource plan that you need.
Financing is just one of
those types of resource.
People are another really
important type of resource.
So this is really, hopefully,
an entire memo to yourself
to say here's where
I am today and here's
what I need going forward.
So I know I just
said a lot, so I just
want to take a minute in
case there's any questions
or if anybody wants to
ask specific questions
about their situation.
That was a really good
overview, I think.
And you hit on a
lot of the things.
Especially almost
doing a gap analysis.
Here's what we've got,
here's where we want to be.
And sort of reverse engineering.
What is it we need?
Who is it that we need?
It really helps everybody to
gain some clarity about that.
So I really think
that was great.
I have two questions
if that's OK.
One is specific to the
creative arts competition.
So I think a lot of our
ideas are pretty early stage.
What's the
expectation that we'll
have unit economics and
financial projections
for the competition?
We like to see that this
has had some due diligence
and some consideration.
We're looking for
real viability,
but you also don't
have to hand us
a perfect, comprehensive 10-year
plan, anything like that.
So if you use these
sorts of workshops,
we'll also make some
other resources available.
We'd like to see something
at least preliminary.
And in the second part
of the competition,
there's a lot of one on
one mentorship with people.
And when you apply,
you can also indicate
we need help with marketing.
Or we need help
with our slide deck.
We need help with
a business plan.
And ideally, you'll be
matched with a mentor who
will be able to help you
through those sorts of things.
So tell you what
you're doing right,
strengthen any muscles that
need a little more attention.
So having a basic idea
and an understanding
of how this all fits into
place is really helpful,
and there will also be more
guidance and resources.
Got it.
OK, perfect.
That's helpful.
And my second question is for
business plans in general.
Carly, how often do you think we
should be evolving and updating
this document?
Especially if we're
treating it as a master text
Yeah, I think that's
a great question.
But I also want to just go
back to your first question,
too, because I think a
couple ideas for you--
have you even started to explore
the idea of unit economics
for your business?
No, not really.
[INAUDIBLE] January on that.
Yeah.
So Fuse, in particular,
will be a great place.
So one way for--
you're a traditional e-commerce
business at its heart?
So I think the good
part about that
is that there are
some existing tactics.
Whether it's putting
up a landing page
or testing some Instagram ads.
I don't know if you
have sandbox funding,
but that could be a really good
use for that type of funding.
Just to test some ads and
figure out, for instance,
there's a unit economic--
I don't know if you're
familiar with it--
called Cost Per Click.
So figuring out how
many people are clicking
on my ad, what was
the cost of that ad,
and then dividing it by
the number of clicks,
and then that's just
a starting ground.
But the other way, just
because you are in a world
that's pretty known.
Obviously, you're trying
to do something different.
But you could
definitely look also
at other e-commerce or
direct-to-consumer businesses
when you're doing some
market landscape just
to see if there's
some comparables,
whether that's specific
businesses or expected
averages.
That stuff changes
all the time, so you
want to make sure that that
market research is reasonably
up to date.
Obviously another new digital
marketing channel, TikTok,
hasn't been around a lot,
but there's definitely
some interesting and creative
ways for customer acquisition
in that front.
So those are two ideas.
I think you'll have
a ton if that would
be a goal of yours in Fuse.
I think that you could
easily get a bunch of help
there doing that and
testing some digital ads.
But the other thing
is there's definitely
some comps in the
market that you could
use as a placeholder for now.
And then, I think in
terms of updating,
I think it's a good question.
So is this a document
that you might always
want to have open
and updating whenever
you're getting an opportunity?
Probably, but I don't
know if that's realistic.
So what I would say is, I
think having it as a calendar
reminder once a month
or blocking it out
for two hours just to
look at it I think,
is a really good thing.
Not only because I'm sure
at the stage of business
you're at you're going to have
lots to update, but I think,
again, it's just a good
document to help you reflect.
And also help you
say, OK, here's all--
these are basically
every single bullet point
is something to figure
out in your business.
It's like open questions.
And so if you can even use
this as a reminder to say,
hey, here's the
10 open questions
I need to continue to figure
out how to understand.
Oh, I've spent a lot
of time this month
on prototyping my website and
doing customer interviews,
but I forgot to try
that digital ad thing.
It'll just help
you stay grounded
and be able to see the big
picture so you're not really
missing anything
in the near term.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, totally.
That's really helpful.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
And for you, this
is going to be--
I would also say the
use for you in this is,
eventually when you
do find a teammate--
whether that's a co-founder
or just a teammate,
it doesn't have to be a
co-founder necessarily--
this is a great way to
get them on your page
and help them understand
what you've already done.
And the slide was just--
I think I demonstrated
that in the prior slide.
But in my opinion,
your business plan
should really be
all encompassing.
So there might be
sections that I
didn't include
that you might say,
I want to talk about x or y.
And so feel free to add
it and to iterate it
based on that general template.
And then I do want
to plug this--
this is the framework that
we use at the Trust Center
discipline entrepreneurships.
So if you want a
framework to figure out
how to answer all
those questions,
discipline entrepreneurship
is absolutely
a great one to leverage.
So the graphic you're seeing
on the left hand of the screen
is the 24 step framework.
If you're not familiar
with this entrepreneurship,
I would number one say it's
an incredibly easy read.
It's not a traditional
business text.
It really is not intimidating,
you can read it in a weekend.
I'm not a person who loves
to read a book on a weekend,
but I can easily read discipline
entrepreneurship in a weekend.
And it really does
take you step by step,
and you'll realize once you're
going through these that it
becomes much easier to
answer those questions.
And these are-- the bullet
points on this slide
are the high level
points that I think
this framework is really, really
useful to help you answer.
And by the way, in
the right order,
you want to understand who
your customer is before
designing the product for
that customer, for instance.
Once you understand the
customer and the product,
then the question is
how is my customer going
to find this product?
How am I going to make money?
What are the unit economics?
And then eventually,
how do I actually
scale this for impact
getting back to that vision?
And so really the last
slide I have again is
the benefit of doing all
this work because I know
that a business plan can be a
tremendous amount of writing
and a tremendous amount of work.
But it will make a
lot of things easier.
It's doing the legwork to
help you be more efficient
in the long run, frankly.
And so communication, again,
is one of those things
that it can take
you a ton of time
to explain to an investor what's
going on in your business,
or new hire that you just met
that you're super excited about
and you want to
email immediately.
So hopefully it's
obvious to see the value
of putting some real thought
into this business plan memo
and taking some time to really
build it out so that you can
react really, really
quick to people
who you want to
communicate to questions
that are asked of you.
I think about it as a cheat
sheet for my business.
So that is all I
have for you guys.
I hope that was helpful
and happy to stick around
for questions.
But I will also say we have a
ton of resources on our website
entrepreneurship.mit.edu
and Orbit, which
has a huge knowledge base.
So if you want more
resources in the meantime,
that's a great place to go to.
Thank you so much.
This was great.
It was so straight forward
and well conceived.
I think this will
be really helpful.
Does anybody else
have questions?
I have a few things
that came up,
but Sida, you have
any questions?
I have a question
for Carly that's
not specific to business
plans so maybe she--
Yeah, yeah.
Go for it.
Want to go first?
OK.
So Carly, you
mentioned that Crabwalk
is a venture-backed startup.
So curious to get your thoughts
on what are the considerations
that we should
take into mind when
deciding whether to go down
the VC financing path or not?
And how does that affect
the day-to-day operations.
I feel like I have
a hunch, but I would
love to hear your thoughts.
Yeah.
It's a fantastic
question, and I think
one that's probably
not asked enough,
especially around a campus
like MIT where, or venture--
frankly, VCs are
all over campus.
And second, it's
fun to talk about.
It feels like a huge milestone
to raise a big amount of money.
And so the first thing I
will say about that is I
think that's the wrong attitude.
I think instead of
saying congratulations
when somebody races around,
it should be good luck.
Because basically what
you're signing up for,
to start answering
your question,
is you're signing up to return
a lot more in capital than you
took.
Venture is an asset class
where they don't want just two
times their money back.
They want 10x or
100x their money.
So first of all, you have to be
ready to be on their timeline.
Typically what they want you
to do is return their money.
So that level of return
in five to seven years,
or sometimes now more like
seven to 10 years timeline.
So if you want to have a
hypergrowth scale for impact
business-- and that scale
for impact is a big deal.
That's why people do want to
take venture money, and they do
want to become founders
a lot of the time,
because they want
to have that impact.
And you really do, capital
is your way to get there.
To have money to grow
your business to a scale
where not only are the
returns great for you
and the investors, but the
impact of your business
is great for your
customers and society
depending on what
the business is.
So the first thing
I would say is
you have to be ready
to be on that timeline
and that hypergrowth mentality.
And so if you don't have those
fundamental questions answered
in the business plan, for
instance, you're probably--
you may or may not be ready
to be on that growth path.
And then I think the
second thing is--
so actually, so
personally to me,
my business partner
just wasn't interested.
We both came from
venture-backed startups.
She's actually a full-time
career coach in her day job
when mine is at MIT.
And she said, I'm
really burnt out
on that type of
business building.
Maybe we'll do that one day,
but it's actually not something
I'm interested in right now.
So she made the decision for
us, and I was supportive of that
just given the whole picture
of our lives right now.
We didn't decide
to do that 100%.
And so the second part
of that on the other side
is, do you think your
business can return that?
When you figure out
those unit economics
and you figure out
that business model,
is your business going to
have a venture-backed return?
Because there's
a lot of startups
that simply aren't, and
that's totally fine.
But you should have an idea--
not in detail-- but high level.
How would I even go about
returning that money?
And are the economics of
my business ever going
to get to a point where I
could be having $100 million
in revenue every month?
Monthly recurring revenue
or annual recurring revenue.
And if the answer is no,
then that's totally fine.
An e-commerce business,
direct-to-customer,
that's a business model that
has tipped a lot of times--
not all the time--
but has proven that
can return because they
don't have heavy assets of
a brick and mortar store.
That's what you're
trying to disrupt.
But those businesses-- there's
some really big successes,
and then sometimes there's
other challenges like logistics
and that sort of stuff.
So I hope that answers
your questions.
It does, yeah, no.
I really appreciate the
perspective, and I agree.
Definitely not something
we talk about much,
and I wish there was more
conversation around it.
If you're at that point
where you're not quite
a venture-backable business,
where [INAUDIBLE]----
but you don't quite
have enough funding
to continue going forward.
What are the different
financing options
available at that point?
Yeah, so the best
source of financing
always is revenue
from customers.
So that's why focusing
on the customer
early is so important
to us because,
to have that option even--
there's some great
stories from business--
and I'd be happy to
send you one or two
that I have in my
mind-- of companies
bootstrapping until they're $10
million in monthly revenues.
And then them
saying, OK, if I want
to get past this I really
need some venture capital.
And the whole idea
of venture capital
is that you're trading ownership
in your company for money.
And so if you can get
to a crazy milestone--
I'm not saying that's
easy-- but if you actually
have the capacity to raise
revenue from your customers
or get in the medical
community or the deep science
community like the NIH, or other
different grant opportunities.
That is equity-free money.
MIT there is a lot
of equity-free money.
Not in the millions, but in
the tens of thousands for sure,
if not $100,000 if you were
to win the 100K competition.
The further you can go
before taking venture money,
the more of your company
you will be able to own.
So if you do have that really
crazy return on the other end,
you can really profit from it as
opposed to just your investors.
Yeah, all you have to do
is win this competition.
That's the easiest path.
Honestly, it's easier than going
through that whole headache
of trying to raise venture
and being stuck with them.
This is a little bit of pain
for a short amount of time.
That's a lot of different
type of pain for a lot longer.
So I've heard a few stories
like you can't divorce anyone
who invests in your business.
And so it's the
only relationship
you can't get out of.
One thing that I
think is interesting
is writing a business
plan is often
kind of a clarifying, sometimes
transformative, process
for ideas.
Do you have any examples
of a good before
and after of an idea with going
through that business plan
process?
It's a good question.
I don't have one
that comes to mind.
But I think a common
thing that happens
is people are not specific
enough with their customer
in particular or the way
they want to go to market.
So even saying, oh we're
a consumer business.
We're going to go and
do digital advertising.
I hear that from
students all the time.
And I'm like, great.
Tell me more about that
digital advertising.
What's the cost of
customer acquisition?
What is the cost per
click of your ad?
What does that funnel look like?
And so I think that the
transformation that typically
happens is you think you have
a level of specificity that's
enough, but in reality when
you actually go to write it
out, or go to try to communicate
to somebody that sort of is
in a position to give
you real feedback,
it's not nearly specific enough.
So I think it really
helps to narrow in.
I think that's really
good advice, especially
since we have such
a heavy mentorship
component in this competition.
And if people want to take
the most advantage, maximize
their time with people, having
greater specificity to then get
feedback on that is a lot better
than taking someone's time
as they walk you
through that process.
Wherever you are, it's great.
If you need to help finding
that specificity, we're here.
But if you have the capacity
for that ahead of time,
you can really maximize the
mentorship opportunities.
Yeah, and I would add to that.
I think that's totally
right, Shannon.
And people, especially
mentors, they
want to brainstorm with you.
They want to actually help
you, and they can't help you
if you're just having-- if
the whole conversation is
about getting you to
explain what you're doing.
If you actually
present them with,
I tested this, A versus B,
and this is what happened.
Then they're going to be like,
oh that's such a great test.
And oh, tell me what
you learned, and here's
five other ideas
of other things you
can test as opposed to
you starting to say, oh,
I'm going to have a
digital marketing--
I saw the industry averages.
$15 cost per click, and
it's like, OK, great.
That doesn't really tell
me anything specific.
It doesn't give me an idea
of your thought process
as an entrepreneur or executor.
You've done some
basic market research
and have some basic assumptions.
But to really go the
extra mile and hopefully
your business plan
can sort of reveal
when you need to do
that, will really
help you have much more
productive conversations
and utilize the resources
of this competition
and the other resources around
MIT a little bit better.
So in that same
vein, what happens
if you change your mind?
What happens if you need
to evolve your idea?
What happens if
you're not growing?
Or if you miscalculated
your risks?
How do you change your
existing infrastructure?
Especially in response
to either failure
or constructive
criticism from a mentor,
or whatever it might be.
Yeah.
So that obviously gets
more difficult over time,
but it's never too late.
I will use the big
tech story of last week
to give everybody an example.
So slack, which just sold to
Salesforce for $26 billion,
was a video game application.
And I think--
I don't know the number off
the top of my head of venture
capital that they
burned, but they
were a full-fledged company.
And by the way, Stewart
Butterfield, who is the CEO,
this was his second rodeo.
So it's not like he wasn't
experienced as an entrepreneur
and an executor.
He had built Flickr
before, which I
believe was a different pivot.
I don't know if you guys
are old enough to remember.
Flickr which was a photo
app that sold to Yahoo.
It was one of the
original photo apps,
and he made a second
pivot with Slack.
It was literally
a video game app.
Slack was a chat, an internal
messaging tool that they used.
And then they decided to get
all their investors together,
tell them he wasn't going
to return their money,
he was going to reinvest the
money in this new business
and he hoped that
they were on board.
I can't remember
if they gave people
an opportunity to buy
out or not at that point.
And obviously that
was a great success.
That's extreme, I'm not
saying that's your pivot.
But I think to try to answer
your question more literally
and more something that people
can actually take away from it
is, you need to--
the first thing is,
you need to figure out
again the specific things
you want to change,
and you need to be able
to communicate that.
So I think the most important
thing, and what I'm sure
Stewart did right, was that he
was able to communicate exactly
why what he was doing
wasn't working anymore
and where he was going.
He had a new vision.
He had a new mission statement.
He had a new business plan.
And so I'm sure what
he was able to do
was very effectively communicate
that not only to his investors,
who he needed to, in theory,
get on board, to his board
members, who I'm sure
had to approve the pivot,
and then to his
employees, who he
was going to change the
entire purpose of their job.
And they were no longer working
at a gaming company, which
is certainly a specific type
of culture of a startup,
to an enterprise chat solution.
Which is a really different
type of company to build.
So I don't think anybody should
ever be scared of pivoting.
I get students who are four or
five months into their venture
they say, you know,
this isn't working.
And then they just keep
bumping against it,
but they're too scared.
And it's like, well, I
already put this much time
into my business.
There's so much more
time, hopefully,
on the other side
of this decision.
So whatever-- I think one of
the most frustrating parts
about entrepreneurship is
that it's not efficient,
and the sunken
costs are something
that's really hard
for us to let go of.
And I think that's actually one
of the most important muscles
that you can build in early
stage startups is learning how
to be OK with saying goodbye
to your sunken costs,
with saying goodbye
to the time you just
wasted trying a bunch of
stuff that didn't work.
And it's that analogy--
I don't have a better
analogy than this,
but it's what people say
when you have a baby.
You forget all the pain a minute
after you see your child's face
for the first time.
It's the same thing.
You could-- I have students
who they've made 10 pivots.
I run delta v in New York.
We pivot all summer
sometimes for teams.
I had a team in 2018
called [? Rune. ?]
They started as a
customer service app.
They had natural
language processing,
and so they decided--
they came into delta
v, they pitch me
on this awesome idea I
was super excited about,
helping to train customer
service agents a lot
more fast and efficiently.
And they pivoted for two
months into the program
and didn't land on their
existing idea till August 5th.
Delta v is a three month
program, it ends August 30.
And that was really
well worth it.
they did such an amazing job.
And 2 and 1/2 years later
they went through YC,
they raised $2 million,
and they're still
in business in San Francisco.
So even though they
might have felt
like they had, at that point,
six months of sunken costs,
it was it was an unbelievable
reflection on them
as entrepreneurs to see that
they were willing to pivot.
And this isn't the most
comfortable environment.
They had board meetings
they had to go to.
They had mentors
they were telling
what they did all summer.
And they just stood
there proudly and said,
you know, we're pivoting.
What can we say.
We're not going
to nail it until--
we're not going to
do this until we're
super excited about what we're
doing, and it really paid off.
And I have a lot
of the stories too.
That is really-- you've got
to have a little bit of nerve
to pivot late in the
process like that.
But I think that's
a good point, and I
think that the Slack
example was really poignant.
This has been a great--
an hour is definitely
not enough time,
and there's so much talk
about entrepreneurship.
But if you have one takeaway
or one pearl of wisdom
to share with folks
who are looking
to compete in this creative arts
competition or entrepreneurship
competitions more broadly.
What would that key takeaway
or pro of wisdom be?
Yeah, I'm going to sound
like a broken record,
but it's really your
ability to communicate
is the most important thing.
You can have the coolest idea in
the world, the coolest product,
but if you cannot communicate
that to others and you
can't get people
excited about it,
or ultimately buy your
product, it doesn't matter.
There are so many
cool technologies
that never got off the
ground, or cool technologies
that where the
inventor didn't end up
getting credit because
they weren't the ones
to commercialize it.
The MP3 being one of the
best examples in history.
And so not only should
you focus on communication
and it shouldn't be a
second thought, it really
should be one of
your primary focuses,
just like technology and
product development is
for so many of us at MIT.
Practicing communication is
just the most important thing.
And not only for
this competition
that I know, but
really in the long run.
And figuring out not only
what you're going to say,
but how you're going
to deliver it--
equally important.
I have a question.
Sure.
What would be your opinion?
Is there an important difference
between our focused businesses
and other types of
businesses such as technology
focused ones?
And the other question
would be, what
would be the key challenges
for art projects?
And how can we face them?
Yeah, that's a great question.
So the first thing
I will say is that I
think creative arts businesses
can be technology businesses.
So they can be two
different things, but they--
for the purpose, especially
this competition,
they're one and the same.
Or they need to be combined.
And then, frankly, one of the
challenges with this sector
overall is that in a way,
there's so much opportunity
because there's been so many
business models and arts that
have been really challenged
since the internet
when you think about
music in particular.
One of my first things I
was thinking about when
you answered that question
is, the size of the market
sometimes isn't as big in arts
as it is in other industries,
but then I think about
Spotify and the music market.
And I was just listening to
somebody talk about this.
And I think it was Kara
Swisher, who I'm a huge fan of,
she's a technology reporter.
And she was talking about how
in no other medium has there
been such an elegant
solution to have
every single song in the world.
You can't have every TV show
on a single app right now.
You can't-- I guess you
can have every book,
but with audible
and some other--
I don't even know what
the book apps are,
but Spotify was such a feat.
But it's difficult, right?
And I think creative arts
like every other industry
is getting eaten by the
really big tech giants.
And so everybody now is
trying to play in music.
Apple, Amazon, Google, and
it's a really interesting time
to be in creative arts.
I think even now with COVID
you see all the theater
artists in particular
having to completely rethink
the entire way that
they do things.
I think there's a lot of
challenge in this area
and in this industry,
and in a way that's
the most exciting thing
for entrepreneurs,
to see all the
opportunity and try
to wade through all the mess
that's happening right now.
So hopefully it's a
really exciting year
in particular to really
be innovating in the arts.
Thank you.
All right.
I could probably talk to you
for 16 more years about Covid
innovation in the
arts, but that's not
why we're here tonight.
If anybody has any
other questions
I would like to encourage that.
And if not, thank
you so much, Carly.
This was really fantastic.
Great conversation,
great presentation.
I really appreciate
your being here.
And thank you to
everybody else who came.
Really great questions,
very engaging.
This was a delight.
Yeah, thank you guys.
This is really fun, and thanks
for all the great questions.